the holidays are just around the corner
and that means shopping for those that
you love and giving back to those in
need and to help you with your holiday
shopping klorna is such an easy way to
keep an eye on your budget this season
and it's an all-in-one shopping tool
that allows you to split the cost of
your gifts into four
interest-free payments now we're teaming
up with them to shine a light on two
young drew gutters that i got the
pleasure
of spending the afternoon with please
welcome connor and sophia
[Applause]
i'm sophia and i'm eight and i'm in
second grade my organization
is called sophia's books game hi i'm
connor and i'm eight years old and i
raised money for the eastern animal
shelter at the beginning of the year me
and my mom were talking about how to
help people during coverage because they
were losing their jobs and didn't have
that much money and i wanted to send
books to kids that don't have any
i started to raise money for the animals
because i really love my dog cheetah and
he passed away
i think all pets should have as much
love as he did so far we collected five
thousand dollars so far i've given out 2
300 bucks i'm going to raise more money
and get more food for the animal shelter
because pets are like our family i am
making sure that all kids have books to
read and will love reading forever
i mean as the mother of two kids
i find them so inspiring well clarna is
also giving back they've partnered with
build a bear to donate 10
000 bears
to toys for tots to help make sure
children in need across the country have
gifts to unwrap this holiday season and
to celebrate they helped me plan
something really fun for connor and
sophia who thought they were just coming
to our studios to meet a producer but
you know we like surprises around here
and i ended up having the best time
anyway just take a look
hey everybody i'm about to meet connor
and sophia
and i am so excited
[Music]
hi connor hi hi sophia hi
oh my gosh sophia i love your dress
thank you connor i love your haircut
thank you yes
hey you guys i have something that i was
hoping to show you do you want to come
with me yeah
i have a little surprise for you here
[Music]
welcome to build a bear
welcome welcome connor sophia we're so
excited to have you with us today do you
want to make a furry friend yes awesome
drew you can do it too absolutely okay
we have a great selection for you guys
today you can pick anything that we have
here on the wall
what do you guys think
i want the blue bear perfect choice
connor let's face it the blue bear with
that yellow outfit is really fantastic
what do you think sophia
the bunny
i got the bunny too
hello how are you
i'm fine
my name is
bunny my name
is
funny oh
maybe we're
twins
before we get started does anybody want
to add a scent cotton candy cotton candy
for connor sophia what do you think
follow them bubble gum i love it i'm
gonna pick bubble gum too because i want
to be just like my twin i'm gonna get
this stuffer going
step on that pedal for me
what do you think drew oh
that feels great
hi everyone welcome i think that matches
your dress kind of perfectly i know
exactly the one i want to pick connor
can you help me do you think i should
pick the black sneakers or the red
sneakers the red one
i'm looking at your outfit and i really
like your style so
i trusted you we've got some fun
headbands i'm gonna go here great taste
awesome let's come right over here to
this table we'll start getting
everything ready do you want to wear
this headband
are you okay to mess up that awesome
hairdo yes all right
here we are working with stuffed animals
but you take care of real animals
right
what's important to you with taking care
of animals they have food and homes
don't you raise money to take care of
the animals
that's a really big deal
i'm so impressed
sophia you started donating books
that's really impressive how did you
fall in love with books
it takes me to magical places
and it feels like i'm in another world
you wanted other people to be able to go
to magical lands too i wanted them to
love reading the more you read the more
you learn
and the more you learn the smarter you
get oh my god gosh
what grade are you in
second
well this was so
fun and i gotta tell you i think we're
all looking pretty cool
yay
i mean i just love sophia and connor so
much
again as the mother of two kids we hope
that we can parent in a way we hope that
we can raise our children in a world
where they're thinking about donating
books or taking care of animals these
children are not just an inspiration to
other children they're a inspiration to
me as an adult
and they're a perfect reminder to do
some good over the holidays thank you
clarna and thank you to build a bear
[Music]